on
le sénat vient de voter une loi pour
renforcer le modèle de volontariat des
sapeurs-pompiers en france vous savez il
ya deux cent cinquante mille 50 et 80%
d'entre eux sont bénévoles et sur cette
loi permet de consolider ce modèle
spécifique de sécurité civile
d'organisation de sécurité civile en
france il fallait d'abord renforcer le
statut du sapeur pompier volontaire y
est inadmissible que des pompiers soient
insultés voire caillassé il est
inadmissible que dans certains secteurs
par certains quartiers les sapeurs
pompiers ne soit pas ne puisse pas
intervenir et joker nous l'avons
cherchée par cette loi bien renforcé à
protéger les premiers part de nouveau
disponible et puis la loi va permettre
aussi de nouveaux modèles d'absence avec
les employeurs pour libérer du temps
d'intervention sur le temps de travail
c'est aussi par la loi la possibilité
d'expérimenter un dispositif commun de
l'ensemble des plateformes d'urgence de
l'ensemble des moyens d'urgence appeler
des civils les samu et donc pendant deux
ans une expérimentation pour art des
plates formes communes va pouvoir être
engagée sur les territoires et puis un
move pour la vienne puisque ce samedi
inauguration à poitiers de la nouvelle
caserne saint-eloi qui a complètement
été rénovés c'est un engagement que nous
avions pris avec marie-jeanne bellamy la
présence ils disent il y avait près de
six ans et donc je ne pourrais pas y
être retenu par d'autres engagements
ailleurs mais j'aurai une grosse pense
évidemment pour les pompiers de poitiers
puis un message est évidemment de
soutien et d'amitié à tous les
sapeurs-pompiers de la vienne
[Musique]